دكتور محمد زقوط انت مدير عام المستشفيات
في قطاع غزه ما المعلومات المتوفره عن
الاستهداف لمستشفى
الشفاء المعلومات المتوفره ان جيش
الاحتلال قام بقصف مبنى القدس الطابق
الاخير من مبنى القدس وهو طابق وهو مبنى
ملاصق تماما للمبنى الرئيسي لمجمع الشفاء
الطبي واحنا يعني كنا قد وضعنا به اسر
جرحى كاستن شن او امتداد للاسر
ويحتوي على جرحى
ومصابي هذه الحرب طبعا هو ضرب الط الشمسيه
ولكن خرق ايضا الجدار الموجود في الطابق
الاخير مما ادى الى وقوع شهداء وجرحى من
بين المصابين المتواجدين على اسره
المستشفى هذه جريمه جديده لم تحدث من قبل
جريمه تسجل الى جرائم الاحت اسمح لي اتوقف
معك عن ما الذي تم استهدافه انت قلت شيء
تم استهداف الطابق الاخير الطابق الاخير
من مبنى القدس الطابق الاخير من مبنى
القدس
تفضل نعم هذا الطابق يعني
بالاساس به جرحى وتم اعتماده لقله الاسره
الموجوده في المستشفى وتم تدمير طبعا
الطاقه الشمسيه اللي يعتمد عليها بشكل
جزئي تم تدميرها بالكامل بالاضافه الى ان
الشظايا
والصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها اخترقت الحائط
في المبنى الاخير وادى ذلك الى وقوع شهداء
وجرحى لا نعلم كم العدد الى الان نحن في
تواصل دائم مع الاخوه في مجمع الشفاء ولكن
لا نعلم العدد الى الان بالليله ايضا تم
استهداف مستشفى الرنتيسي واستشهد سته من
النازحين ومبنى مستشفى النصر للاطفال
واستشهد اثنان من النازحين داخل المستشفى
يعني اصبح الان الاحتلال يتعمد استهداف
المستشفى مباشره من الداخل واصابه مباني
المستشفى التي يتم فيها تقديم الخدمه بشكل
مباشر وسافر
وعلني لديكم تخوف من ان النيه هي ليست
التخويف وانما تصعيد الاستهداف
للمستشفى انت تتحدث الان عن ثمان شهداء
سقطوا الليله في مستشفى الرنتيسي والنصر
والعشرات من الجرحى وتتحدث عن شهداء الان
يسقطون في مبنى القدس في الشفاء هذا لا
هذا لا يعتبر تخويف التخويف يكون باحداث
اصوات او او او او انفجارات قريبه ولكن
واضح ان هذا استهداف مباشر وهذا قصف مباشر
للمستشفيات قصف مباشر للمدنيين الموجودين
ايضا مستشفى العيون تم قصف الليله وتم
وجود خراب وتدمير في غرف العمليات ومستشفى
الطب النفسي الوحيد الموجود في قطاع غزه
رايتم بالصور وبالفيديو كيف تم استهدافه
هذه جرائم تتكرر اصبحت وكانها شيء اعتيادي
لدى الاحتلال ولا احد يحرك ساكنا نحن لا
نجد اين نضع مرضانا الان الاحتلال يتصل
يريد ان يخلي الشفاء ويريد ان يخلي مستشفى
الاطفال يعني انا لا ادري مستشفى اطال
يريد ان يخليه بالكامل ماذا يريد من وراء
مستشفى اطفال كل هذه يعني شيء يعني لا
يصدق وغير معقول على
الاطلاق من يمكن ان يتدخل لوقف كل ذلك
انتم المستشفيات لها حرمتها لكن من يمكن
ان يتدخل يوقف هذا الامر ويحمي المستشفيات
من الاستهداف
ن يعني اول شيء احنا اليوم طلبنا من
الصليب الاحمر انه يتدخل لاخراج الجرحى من
الشفاء
ومن ومن الاندونيسيه وبالفعل تم اخلاء
بعضا من الجرحى يعني يعني احاد يعني يمكن
تسع مرضى جرحى الانتفاضه او جرحى الحرب تم
اخلاهم هذا يعني ان الصليب الاحمر ممكن ان
يتدخل ممكن ان يعمل شيء لضمان مامون ولو
جزئيه للمستشفيات او للجرحى هذا من جانب
الى جانب انه كل المجتمع الدولي وكل
الاخوه العرب والمسلمين الاخوه في قطر
الذين يسمعوننا ويعرفون جيدا كيف وضعنا
وكل الدول المجاوره لنا مصر والاردن
يعلمون انهم يستطيعون او باستطاعتهم ان
يفعلوا المزيد من اجل انقاذ هذا الوضع
الماساوي وهذه المجازر التي ترتكب على
شاشات التلفاز ليلا ونهارا وعلى مدار
الساعه واصبحت المستشفيات بالفعل لا
تستطيع الناس اصبحوا يعني يموتون من قله
الخدمه الطبيه من كثر القصف المتواصل ليلا
ونهارا على المدنيين ومربعات كامله تستهدف
وعشرات من الشهداء والمئات من الجرحه يعني
هذا شيء غير معقول يعني على الاطلاق انا
الان اطل في مجمع ناصر بجانب صيدلي هو على
راس عمله قد فقد ولديه وبنته وزوجته مصابه
باصابات متوسطه الى خطيره وابوه وامه قد
اصيبوا وهو الان بجانبي بجانب المشرحه هو
على و راس عمله ولا يدري وهم يعني امنون
لا يوجد اي استهداف لاي عسكري في هذا
المبنى وهم امنون ويعني الان يتلقى ابنائه
بين يديه شهداء يعني وضع ماساوي غير مسبوق
على
الاطلاق حقيقه يعجز الانسان احيانا عن فهم
هذا الوضع فيما يتعلق بالمستشفيات وكما
ذكرنا بانها بموجب القانون الانساني
الدولي هي يفترض انها محميه و وهنا السؤال
متى يمكن اعلان هذه المناطق بالفعل وتكرار
هذا الامر على المستوى الدولي بانها اماكن
ينبغي على اسرائيل ان لا تستهدفها باي شكل
من الاشكال كما هي حرمه الاماكن المدنيه
والسؤال هنا سيد زقوت
ا في ظل استمرار هذا الخطر ما الذي يعنيه
بالنسبه للمرضى والجرحى داخل هذه
المستشفيات هذا يعني موت مباشر هذا يعني
استهداف مباشر اخراج هذه المستشفيات عن
الخدمه واستهداف هذه المستشفيات هذا يعني
موت مباشر لالاف ليس لمئات لالاف من
المرضى هذا شيء غير معقول اسرائيل لا تضع
اي اعتبار الاحتلال لا يضع اي اعتبار لا
الاتفاقيات دوليه ولا لاتفاقيه جنيف
الرابع التي تحمي بموجبها المنشات المدنيه
حتى لو عسكري موجود وهو جريح لا يحق لك ان
تستهدفه ما بالك بالاطفال ما بالك بالنساء
ما بالك بالجرحى الذين لا يجدون اي مكان
يتقدم فيه الخدمه مرضى القلب ومرضى الكلى
ومرضى الاورام وال والالاف من المرضى
الموجودين الان في المستشفيات او في
بيوتهم او في مدارس نزوحهم لا يجدون من
يقدم لهم الخدمه هذا يعني قتل عن سبق
اصرار وترصد لهؤلاء المرضى هذا شيء غير
معقول هذا شيء جنوني شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور محمد زقوط مدير عام المستشفيات في
قطاع غزه ونحن نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
لاستهداف جديد في قطاع غزه